Let's define some terms for various camera moves. Here's a top down drawing of
a viewer and an object. When you adjust the field of view, that's zoom. When
you move directly towards or away from an object you're looking at, that's
dollying, it's not zooming. I have a zoom on my camera does not mean, if I want
to make something larger, I run toward it and I yell zoom. It's so easy in
computer graphics to either zoom in or dolly in, that they're sometimes not
that easy to tell apart. However, they're certainly different in their effect
on the camera's field of view and location. The one giveaway that you're
dollying and not zooming is that if new faces become visible or disappear.
Zooming changes the size of the image scene, but does not change visibility.
All that said, I'll sometimes say zoom in, when the controls are actually dolly
controls, just because most people don't know what dolly in means. The camera
controls for most of the programs in this course have the mouse wheel and
middle mouse button set to dolly the view in and out. The other common camera
moves are panning and orbiting. Panning means moving left or right as you keep
the camera pointed forward. For most programs we're using, the right mouse
button pans. Orbitting means circling around the target position, similar to
how a satellite orbits the earth. For those of you into first person shooters,
it's circle strafing a target. The target location is often placed at the
center of whatever object is to be examined. In most of our programs, left
mouse orbits around a target location. Incidentally all these mouse moves are
just what we happen to use. There are no iron clad standards among programs
about which mouse button does what.